2014 wonderful year for video games and
of course it's been an honor to host and
talk to all you wonderful people about
all of the best games are came out this
year and the nominees I want to give a
special shout-out to our friends at air
high airheads who have sponsored this
year's Game of the Year nominee
discussions and they wanted to do
something special at the end of this
show so I didn't want to impact on our
normal discussions and sort of exactly
say that is exactly what happened there
would be chewing while we were talking
about dragon age inquisition to work all
day you're lucky you're looking at in
this discussion because I'm going to be
throwing these at people's faces pretty
soon okay and we gamespot of old used to
do a lot of interesting sort of them off
platform nominees like best arched is
you know technical best art best
competitive multiple yeah cooperative
multiplayer best story best ending best
character exactly so I wanted to heart
back to those days so I've got five
questions I've told you the questions I
don't know what the answers are both of
you are going to have to try and
convince me that you have the right
answer for this and I'm going to throw
arrows at you while you do if you win if
you win you get our heads alright so we
might questions I hope you put good
thought into this because me and Chris
are going to be criticizing your pretty
good we've been talking for an hour and
45 minutes next we're pretty good oh
yeah Shatner salty so first one biggest
game disappointment of 2014 Alexa I have
the right answer in its assassin she
Assassin's Creed unity okay why so not
only was it sort of like didn't really
iterate I'm previously sounds good
mechanics too much but also like
Assassin's Creed associate store is
usually pretty good they want you to
care for the character put that whole
Abstergo thing jumped the shark so many
games ago and I didn't care about the
relationship between the two
protagonists if it's looking love story
can really work out yeah I didn't
believe it and I just thought it was not
that good when really all right Peter
brand can you get more disappointing
than that okay so one of the greatest
action series of all time is ninja
gaiden okay an old I know where yes go
in behind that is no longer with the
team of development it's my turn to talk
keep your mouth shut he he's gone but
kohutek mo is developing a new Ninja
Gaiden game and within like developing
it they had keiji inafune e that man
behind megaman and guy behind onimusha
he also worked on some of the Resident
Evil games is a wonderful game designer
what the result was yeah but Ninja
Gaiden Z
yeah a que a steaming pile of crap this
game had a really eye-catching
presentation but it had a horribly like
non funny vulgar script the action did
not flow well together at all and this
is a game that's designed on this like
legacy of a great action series it had
beautiful graphics but using them they
just basically put out a lot of just
like vomiting and like blood spewing it
wasn't actually put to great effect mmm
the game had a pedigree behind it could
have been great turnout on man just
zombies the game yeah this is hard
because I was anticipating watchdogs to
be mentioned which kind of fell into the
assassins creed section but I remember
playing ninja gaiden Yaiba Ninja Gaiden
Z I'm thinking man this is a piece of
hot trash so Peter Brown you win first
one yes airheads bites size bra round
one winner mr. peter bran alright ran
too ok you thought that one was hard
what was your biggest surprise of 2014
Peter go bigger surprise for me was
sunset overdrive ok after many previews
that were written on gamespot and here
and talking about colleagues like oh
yeah this game is just you know it's not
really there I was assigned the review
and a couple hours in I was like I like
it's pretty as hell but you know nothing
really there eventually that game 2
opened up and it was just a blast to
play I could I could skate my way on top
of rooftops you know electric lines like
all the way across the city find these
ridiculous guns destroying like huge
Strong's of enemies and there was no
slowdown at any point it was just a
really really fun game and unlike Ninja
Gaiden Z where this tried to be really
vulgar it did so in a way where you
didn't feel like the actors were forcing
it okay like the swears rolled off their
tongue the insults kind of rolled off
their tongue and in this sort of like
you know aftermath of like you know
horrible apocalypse for most games take
it and like everything's really
downtrodden they were played hearted
about the whole thing like yeah shit's
[ __ ] up but you know what whatever
words going with so here's a gun strong
argument also almost exactly on woman at
well done Alexa go for it be that mill
earth shadow of mordor okay think of
every Lord of the Rings game that has
ever come out the exceptions maybe the
EA two towers Return of the King games
when they announce this game everyone
went to Lord of the Rings game and then
they started showing footage cuz that IP
has been treated pretty poorly yeah uh
and then they started showing footage
and people were like oh it's just Batman
lord of the ring
this Assassin's Creed with erigor and
like stuff like that and then they
started showing the number system and
people are like okay maybe and then the
game came out and everyone freaking
loves it not only has it rejuvenated the
lord the rings IP what is rejuvenated
the action-adventure genre and that's
like the right answer you know what this
side of the release of shadow of mordor
it's easy to forget that we had super
middle-earth chatter more their apathy
bought a couple of months earlier I
remember Michael the platter coming on
our stage at e3 and on one not two but
three three times I'm talking about the
Nemesis sister and even then even it
seemed really good but even then it
didn't it didn't it was on one of the
planes a claymore man that sounds cool
but yeah damn I don't know if you're
gonna pull that off at all but sunset
overdrive is a pretty good shot but you
don't win it's on board are more doors
Oh what question free the air sign
airheads bites size bra mother this is a
good one which console in 2014 had
better exclusives obviously it's PC but
let's find out about the two other one
system Wars I'll question Alexis system
worth the question go uh my vote is for
the position for okay and my argument is
because most of the games that are
showing really innovative really unique
experiences in 2014 have been indie
games on the PlayStation 4 has you know
flow flower and journey but they also
got hokum they got transistor which is
your favorite which wow look at you to
the casing me yeah that don't work and
there's just and there's just so much
and you love surrounding and sort of
looking forward Otto octodad as well hey
you're not thank you experiences are on
you know they're on pc but they're also
console only on PlayStation and I think
moving forward we're gonna see Sony
really cultivating that it was evident
at PSX this past weekend so I think
that's why if I cision for is the best
console okay which console are you going
for Peter there's only one right answer
it's the Wii U oh yeah yeah and my end
my reasoning is mario kart super smash
brothers they netted to captain toad
treasure tracker other games that are no
i think nintendo does some things that
no other company can do
and that is pack these like really
interesting mechanics in two games that
are so approachable by everybody and
they they're so like well refined you
never find issues that plague other
games where things are broken or it's
like inconsistent or there's really poor
pacing and then you have something like
Bayonetta 2 which is just as this tour
de force of like over-the-top action
it's a beautiful game on a system that's
usually like given like kind of like a
short end of the stick when it comes to
technical praise and it's a fantastic
action game that's nearly flawless in
every regard all right I think when you
did the whole married cart and the smash
bros in the agenda scratches record I
noticed no transistor but I bought a wii
u last week so in the interest of not
having buyer's remorse Peter Brown yeah
okay well three she got three for
waiting for I'm counting the numbers the
arrows I am Here I am in charge of the
airheads bites size bra AHA Veeru I am
bizarre did you pop the bite-sized
bought you think I don't have like 50
bucks of this at home I'm in charge 21
right now question for what was the
best-looking visual game of 2014 Peter
Brant Bayonetta 2 okay yeah so okay said
that game is forget the platform that
it's on and that it looks great on
assistant that's that's usually like
given that you know so sure you want me
to get that a super get important forget
about it that game has such incredible
scale to it with such ornate detail and
almost every aspect and it is all like
this the sort of resolution where you're
not like oh yeah it's big but it's kind
of muddy you guys it's screen so big so
they gotta know nothing is dialed down
that game is fast humongous ornate
colorful and has beautiful artistic
designs with Alexa you want to win this
you know what to do what's your video
game was it any success good because
it's beautiful it's colorful it's you
have all those different options part of
what I loved about it is the
customization option you can make
yourself look like anyone you wanted to
look like and flying around that city
know they made you feel powerful but it
was fun to watch yourself fly across
that city and all those colors whizzing
by and all of that sort of brightness
and for a game that sort of really like
it's a really dark like you're fighting
at the apocalypse never one around here
is turning
these monsters I think that that beauty
really lent itself to it and it was just
did I get knocked over my hair has s
pray God did I get one more time you did
you do the Pooh thing it's our heart to
me I became of the airhead my god that's
like we should usurp the fine we know
what we know who it like we know who
wins that one I used to do that bit at
the end that was unnecessary but
collusion pretty much you want one of
those religions all right we got a
deadlock two and two for that way I
guess it's probably best if we do it
that way no sandy it's not fair candy
it's not a bad how much candy maybe not
to you but to me look I've given these
are basically all the presents I'm
bringing home to Ireland for my family
so i can give you only the three that
are left and then the rest of mine the
last question folks the most important
video game question you answered in 2014
to win the airheads bite size bra what
was the weirdest game of 2014 Alexa this
is god of jumping on what he said
earlier i'm going with bayonetta 2 oh
wow because one it's the perfect action
game like we talked about this earlier
it's not weird kenefick well it's weird
because the perfect action game and you
play as a lady makes weapons and close
out of her hair yeah game is just like I
think it's weird personally that it's on
the way you non verb wine Mario beignet
Everett um but it's just the whole
concept of like having just the whole
damn things are totally weird are you
saying it's just not as weird because we
knew about ban at a 1 are you saying of
bayonetta 2 just came out with all the
hair stuff no I think I'm still weird i
played bayonetta one and i still think
the whole thing is sort of a jumble of
weirdness but it works enough and that's
even weirder and it makes you feel super
powerful alright strong contender peter
brown port friends I'm going with sports
friends because it has a bunch of games
including one called johann Sebastian
joust okay where you use the PlayStation
Move controllers and you like circular
on your friends in real life there's no
TV involved you're literally trying to
like jostle your friends and prevent it
from doing stuff that is unusual as hell
are you saying your hands abbasi
just came out in 2014 because i remember
playing that bike it no sir yeah but it
surely did not come out it's an eye on
I'm teleportation move and who owns a
playstation move that is not product why
its weirdos on them no I have asked for
PlayStation Move controllers is weird
like deep Devon PS Move ever since it's
also got the game barbary ball in it but
also the the pole vaulting friends
component where bull rider to purple
riders yeah he's really fouling like our
tanks is sort of like just bump into
each other like proud your friends and
get all weird with your phallus and
what's weirder than that okay at Chris
I'm gonna let you decide we have been at
co hosting this show all year long yeah
I feel like this is a two hearted
assistance I'm gonna ask you to do it so
here I'm gonna throw this at you and
then you throw it onto my back feel
startling I don't like it well I there's
only one game that I have accidentally
in the course of playing the game
bludgeoned a man in his genitals and
that is johann Sebastian joust don't
have one point I got three though oh yes
no whines right so a lady attacking
weird centaurs on the back of a jet with
her hair weird okay domain enough so I
think I final decision here who's going
to win the air heads bite-sized brawl
Bayonetta 2 too weird oh we're looking
at any two seconds of that game and it
is the weirdest crap i have all candy
i'm gonna hang out next to win
you